et
[Musique]
le calme est un peu revenu sur la terre
depuis que l'insecte gégène s'intéresse
à la musique jbe il faut dire car il ya
très peu de gens qu'ils savent ce que
c'est depuis ce temps là que les
insectes sont toujours attirés par les
conseils ajoutons entre parenthèses des
titres ou de conseil le fidèle
téléspectateur que si vous avez chiffres
un insecte genre geiger votre pain
fromage ou vos pieds de table et que
vous vouliez vous en faire un ami
le mieux c'est de lui jouer de la
musique ce n'est pas pour autant qu'il
arrêtera de manger vos pieds de table au
pain et vos fromages mais à coup sûr il
deviendra votre ami alors il viendra
écouter la musique avec au salon et à ce
moment là il vous sera aisé vous en
débarrasser en utilisant les moyens
adéquats
fermons la parenthèse pour gégé c'était
pareil sauf que les hippies trouvais que
c'était d'un insecte absolument charmant
et qu'il n'y avait pas de raison de s'en
débarrasser il partait avec lui faire
des procès à la campagne quelquefois
malheureuse bon gégène oublier qu'ils
n'étaient le terry gégène maître de la
terre et de ses éléments et entraînée
par la musique qu'il se mettait un
sifflet sifflé comme vous le savez qu'il
pleut fait d'autres fois ils sifflent
est aussi pour faire tremblement de
terrre mais gentiment et alors
c'était beaucoup plus amusant à l'eau
les bibis virent que temps que gégène
serait le rap la terre serait pour eux
la plus belle planète à jeu qu'il
n'avait jamais
les shadoks payer
[Musique]